hi this is press talker in this video
I'm going to explain how you can win at
Kinect for every time this is really
cool it's the first time something like
this has been put online so Kinect for
is a board game where two players drop
discs of different colors and the object
of the game is to create four in a row
of your own color discs and you can
create this four in a row horizontally
it can be vertical or it can also be
diagonal in a typical game each player
is going to try and set a trap so that
they can create four in a row but at the
same time the opponent is trying to
block those traps and trying to create
four in a row of their own so what
usually happens is the game goes on for
several moves and it only ends when one
player is forced to play in a spot so
the other player can connect four in a
row or more so in general there are
three ways that you could win in the
game one is your opponent can make a
mistake another is you can create a
double attack or final way you can win
is if the opponent has to be forced to
move in a spot that allows you to win so
we'll go through these in turn so one
way you can win is if your opponent
makes a mistake
so here red should block the three in a
row from the blue but if red plays
incorrectly then that leaves blue open
to make a four in row another way you
can win is if you can create a double
attack so here red is going to make a
mistake and this allows blue to create a
double attack these three blue chips at
the bottom will allow blue to complete a
four in a row
on either the left or the right side so
no matter where red plays blue will
always be able to complete the attack
and complete four in a row
the final way you can win is if both
people are playing very smartly I'll
explain the color codes later the game
will actually go on for many many moves
no player is going to make a mistake no
player is going to allow the other
player to have a double attack and the
way the game ends is when one player red
right here is for
to play in this final column which
allows Blu to place the chip and win on
this final move I'll also mention that
there are ways the game can end in a tie
so there are ways that the disk can be
dropped and neither player can end up
winning the game you can fill up the
entire board what's the interesting part
for us is that Connect four has been
mathematically solved and with proper
play player one can always win this is
the first time a solver like this has
been put online and we can thank
professor Dan Garcia at University of
California Berkeley and his game
crafters group this was a massive
computing project as there are over four
point five trillion board configurations
that they had to go through to figure
out an optimal strategy the bottom line
is that if you play first and follow
this strategy you can always win so what
you want to do I've left a link for the
game crafters website is go to the game
crafters website and select the board
which has seven columns and six rows and
you want to connect four in a row so
this puts you on a screen where you can
play Connect four
so you hover your mouse over the screen
and when you click that will drop the
disc in a particular column to see how
you can win every time click on the
display option for move values this
gives you a color coded value for what
each move will result in the game green
will mean that's a place where you can
have a winning move yellow means it'll
result in a tie and red means you'll
have a losing move so blue plays in the
center and that's a winning move and now
when you look at red no matter what red
does it's always a losing move and the
prediction is that red will lose in 40
moves so let's assume red plays in the
center now there's only one spot that
blue can play to win the game if blue
plays anywhere else it's a mistake and
with proper play red could actually win
the game so it's very important that you
follow the strategy exactly as it's
shown
so blue has to play carefully and here's
an example like after the first column
is filled blue can play to the left to
right to win if blue plays two columns
over from the center column the game
could result in the tie if red plays
properly let's assume blue makes a
mistake and plays in the Far column now
it's actually the case that red can win
the game if red plays in this proper
column and then continues following the
strategy as described by the solver so
the solver will assume that both players
are trying to block they will never make
a mistake by just allowing the other
person to get four in a row easily it
will also assume the other it will also
prevent the other player from getting
double attacks so when both players are
playing optimally what ends up happening
is that you will end up with a forced
win for one player so now we only have a
couple moves left and blue there's only
one spot blue can play and then that
allows right to win by filling up the
board the other cool thing I'll mention
is that game crafters has also solved
different sized boards so instead of
just the seven columns six rows
connecting foreign road there are
different configurations you can have
that have also been solved so let's do
an example of five by five connecting
four in a row
when we look at the move values this
game is actually a fair game in the
sense that it could result in a tie it's
like tic-tac-toe if both players play
properly it could actually end up in a
tie where no one wins but you could make
mistakes and that could lead to a win
for one of the players so it's a really
cool website and you should check it out
I hope you liked this video please
subscribe to my channel you can support
me on patreon catch me on my blog mind
your decisions on Twitter at pressure
Walker and you can get my books listed
on my website